foreign
we just can't have nice things
[Music]
so
this will be my third video on across
the spider-verse
and the first one that I do not enjoy
having to do
I did a video profusely praising the
film I did a video giving a trans
reading of the film
I enjoyed this movie very much this
movie is amazing it is at this point
easily the best thing that I've seen so
far this year
and it was also created through abuse of
workers
uh if you can't tell I'm actually really
ticked about this
well let's get into what we actually
found out
well the morning that I'm recording for
when this comes out uh this past
Thursday
an article came out on vulture in which
four animators many of whom were
Veterans of the industry who had worked
for more than just Sony so like they're
not newcomers who had no idea what they
would get into they're used to the
normal workflow of Animation gave
detailed accounts of not good work
conditions on that film
now if you want to read their full
accounts I encourage you to read that
article it is down in the description
I'll put a link to it
but in short
there was a lot of crunch on this now
crunch is not a term we're used to
hearing as much in the movie industry
it's a very common term in the video
game industry because video games have
almost no unions uh Hollywood and just
movie making in general has a lot of
unions and most of the decent work you
know while paying work high profile work
is Union work and while there is an
animation Guild there is a union for
animators it's not that big and does not
even come close to covering all the
animators working and specifically when
it comes to Sony uh there's a funny
little wrinkle so there's the animator's
guild which as I said does exist and
does what it can and Sony animation
pictures does work with the animation
Guild here's the thing though
the actual
animation work the core of animating
this film not designing and and
um you know storyboarding or any of that
but the actual hard work the actual
day-to-day work of getting the thing
animated
what's not technically done by Sony uh
animation it was done by Sony imageworks
which due to quirks of Hollywood
accounting is considered an independent
entity at a contractor and is not a
union Studio
so as a result uh the reports that we
are having uh come out include news of
up to 77 hour work weeks
and that broke down as 11 hour work days
seven days a week
no days off
and this went on for the tail end before
the release and the reason that that was
happening was because the film was being
tinkered with to a degree that is not
typical for animation at a point way
later in the process when things should
have been locked down
to give you uh sort of a little bit of a
sense of this animation in general
is a much more free flow creative
process in the beginning
they're often uh very collaborative
works there's a reason that not that
many animated films actually have a
locked in script that's finalized before
they start they have a they'll be a
script there'll be a working script but
then animators will start storyboarding
and directors will look at what's being
done and Pitch Out ideas and it's as I
said it's very free form in most uh ways
that animation gets done but that's
early on
what you then do is you take those
storyboards you finalize the story you
you basically edit it before you go to
full animation you do the editing first
and you assemble the movie you know what
it's going to look like before you put
things into full production and finalize
animation
because if you don't do that
what results is a whole bunch of
needless work because if you make your
animators do full finalized finished
polished and in the case of using any
kind of CGI computers final renders of
scenes or shots before you even start
considering well do we want this how
does this flow is this going to work in
the edit then what is going to end up
happening is a bunch of a bunch of
finished work getting thrown out
replaced or made to be redone from
scratch because something isn't quite
what you wanted
and given the amount of work that goes
into a finalized edit a finalized render
there is a reason you do not do that
it is fundamentally disrespectful
to animators and the Very Art of
Animation to make them do full finished
work that you know might well have to be
redone from scratch or thrown out
completely
and what I have just described that
scenario
does appear to be what has happened
now we'll get into a few more details on
this Beyond just the length of the work
week as I mentioned uh there are a few
things that I will say up front
uh Sony did comment on the article in
particular there were some quotes from
Amy Pascal who produced it now the only
thing that they disputed so they didn't
dispute
the 77 hour work week nor did they
um fully dispute the source of most of
the issues and I'll get to that in a
little bit what they disputed was one
thing at least at the time that I read
the article whether they decided to
dispute more sense don't know the one
main thing that they dispute was uh
something described by one of the
animators who was
um interviewed who said that they
lowball the standard salary for
animators basically telling them well
once all the overtime is in it'll be up
to a standard wage which
if true is messed up that is the one
thing that Sony is disputing so I'm not
going to dwell too much on that but it
does bring me to something that I do uh
want to make a point about and I'll do
it now
over time so far as I can tell was paid
good
because that is unfortunately a very
common problem uh in a lot of Animation
uh and 3D rendering jobs whether it be
video game or animation
if overtime was in fact paid well good
that makes this slightly less monstrous
than a lot of current situations but it
also doesn't make it okay
I've unfortunately already seen uh
arguments made that basically amount to
well as long as they got paid over time
that's okay then no
no
a 77 Hour Work Week
is never okay
ever
for anybody full stop period end of
sentence
that is not an acceptable amount of time
to make people work and you can claim
all you want about well they weren't
forced to nobody put a gun to their head
no look
in this situation when the work has to
be done and you as a worker know how
much time needs to be spent to make it
happen and make it be done on deadline
they don't have to put a gun to your
head because you are aware of the fact
that if you don't put in that time the
work does not get finished in an in on
artistic medium if the work doesn't get
finished
then there's nothing to show for
everything you did and so most people
will put in the work and there's often a
um internal environment and social
structure within a company that will put
pressure on you even though technically
nobody orders you to come in and do the
overtime so forget all that nobody
should ever be working 77 hours a week
nobody
ever any job should be working 77 hours
of hard work labor per week Studies have
already shown that anything over 50
hours you get diminishing returns on the
quality of the work being done and
actually it's not uncommon in a lot of
situations like that where after a 50
hour per week once you've hit that
barrier and you keep going the work gets
worse mistakes happen and that has to be
redone it actually gets less productive
so the fact that a 77 hour work week was
claimed and not disputed
is not okay
now you're about to see me get fairly
angry at a number of specific people but
let me say this now I will reiterate it
later do not harass anybody that I name
or mention in this video criticize them
if you want I'm about to but do not go
and harass anybody this message is
brought to you by the alliance of not
being an so I did say that there
were some more specifics now a lot of
this comes down to the producers which
were Chris Miller and Phil Lord who are
known for The LEGO Movie clouded with a
Chance of Meatballs the 21 Jump Street
movie uh and its sequel apparently Phil
Lord
was the primary source of most of the
late changes requests to redo work from
scratch and insistence that the
animators provide them fully finished
rendered stuff that they would then take
into editing and possibly come back and
make them redo now to be fair
there was some word from Sony and they
don't necessarily dispute Phil being the
primary source of these things there is
the context given that he was the
primary go between between the writing
um directing producing team and the
animators so they would have generally
heard him most things from Phil Lord
regardless of whether they were positive
negative or whether they were notes
specific to what he actually wanted or
whether he was conveying a message so
it's possible he was just the messenger
for my purposes it doesn't really matter
if it was him specifically if it was the
team as the whole and he was just the
mouthpiece it does not matter the way in
which these animators were treated for
the amount of work they were made to do
the amount of time they were made to do
it over the per week seven days a week
seven days a week that's people not
getting time to properly rest recuperate
see their families
that is not okay
and as I said brought up earlier with
the general process of animation
you figure out the thing before you put
people to work on final animation and
that does not appear to have happened
and again this is not disputed that for
a big chunk of the early part when a lot
of work could have been done it would
have been rough work but it would have
been work
the animators were doing next to nothing
they were waiting on the story to get
broken and to be brought to them and
then when it finally was they had less
time than they would normally to do
everything
and this was something that Amy Pascal
spoke to and had a uh a couple of choice
quotes on it really does happen on every
film truly honestly it can be a little
bit frustrating but we always try to
explain that this is the process if this
is happening on every film especially an
animated film your process sucks and is
broken and you need to fix it
because this is not how you run
animation
it's worth noting that probably part of
the reason why there's no dispute with
word coming down from Lord that they had
to change this alter this is that that's
honestly super consistent with what we
know about him and um Chris Miller's uh
working process this is in fact the
reason that they were fired from working
on solo a Star Wars story because they
have a very loose way of working on a
film they improvise a lot they throw out
the script they try new stuff and then
they find it later in the edit that's
just how they work and as I said this is
in fact why they were fired off that
film because uh Kathleen Kennedy was so
defensive of that script that she
thought anybody messing with it that
much should not be allowed to continue
she got rid of them and brought in
someone who would just shoot the script
as is
because the script to solo a Star Wars
story was too good to be messed with
regardless a general sort of sense of
chaotic process but really good end
results is kind of the um catchphrase of
Lord and Miller Productions but it
hasn't come with overworking people to
this degree prior to this but what is
being described very much fits with what
we already know about the process of
these people but no Amy Pascal this is
not typical this does not happen on
every movie or at the very least it
shouldn't even if it does even if it
does it shouldn't
that would not make it okay she
continued one of the things about
animation that makes it such a wonderful
thing to work on is that you get to keep
going until the story is right if the
story isn't right you have to keep going
until it is and her response to the
workers who said they had to keep
redoing finished work she said I guess
welcome to making a movie
[Laughter]
go yourself
this is not how these things are
supposed to be done
most of these workers who came forward
with their stories and you should know
Amy Pascal or Phil Lord or Chris Miller
or anybody else involved in this movie
you should be aware of the fact that for
every one person who comes forward and
actually tells their story there's gonna
be a lot who have similar experiences
who don't because even though in the
report these people were anonymized they
are risking a lot by speaking out
because it's distinctly possible
that Phil Lord and Chris Miller don't
realize what an abusive process this is
maybe they don't
maybe it's been so successful for them
for so long and maybe this is the most
off the rail it's gone but maybe nobody
told them because nobody above them is
going to complain as long as it looks
like the work's gonna get done and
nobody below them is going to point it
out to them because
What's it gonna get them fired probably
it's a non-union gig
is that actually how it is I don't know
but either
he's ignorant and should have been made
aware this is like their fourth or fifth
animated film that they've worked on he
should know by now somebody should have
freaking told him that this is unfair
and abusive to the people that he is
um in charge of
and if he did know and did it anyway
then also uh Phil Lord and Chris Miller
go yourselves and Sony of all companies
really shouldn't be flippant about this
because they've been tied to some
nastiness before with what happened with
one of the production companies on
sausage party nitrogen Studios was one
of several animation companies that
worked on that film and the co-director
of that movie Greg Tiernan apparently
made them work overtime for free a total
of 36 of the 83 animators were
blacklisted and left uncredited in the
film due to their complaints and or
leaving the project now to be fair that
was not a Sony Pictures Animation Studio
Sony simply distributed it but they've
been involved in a movie that had this
kind of controversy come out about it so
it's not like they don't know this can
happen and it's not like they haven't
seen the bad press it's not like they
would be surprised that such a thing can
exist so even though Sunny was only the
distributor on that film uh there were
lessons to be learned and apparently
they didn't learn them well that's not
fair I guess they learned to actually
pay people overtime but that wasn't the
only lesson this is not okay and the
dismissiveness
of Welcome to making a movie
that you say to non-union workers in a
business where most people have a union
they can lean on but these people didn't
no
and what's really annoying what's really
annoying is the first part of her
statement
is correct
you keep working on the story till you
get it right
but if you need to keep working on the
story if you need to keep tinkering it
you need to keep fine-tuning it before
you can even let the animators start
properly
you move the release date back
so that they do not have to crunch 77
hours a week and some people might be
about to jump in oh but they did delay
across the spider verse twice in fact
they did officially for covid
I would not be surprised
if kovid was the cover story to make it
not seem like it was being poorly
managed
and the actual reason was exactly as has
been described
they had the animators basically on ice
not getting to even start their work
because they were tinkering with the
story and then even after the animators
finally get handed a story and shots to
do it's then getting tinkered with after
the fact continuously the entire way
through
you know what really pisses me off about
this
it's a great movie
and because it's a great movie a
successful movie financially critically
a Beloved movie already
that's going to be taken as validation
for the way that it was made
and it shouldn't be
and maybe that's how this kind of
treatment has been gotten away with
before or maybe not again maybe it was
worse on this one than others that these
uh producers have worked on or maybe
it's always been this bad and they're
allowed to keep doing it over and over
and over again because their movies are
successful
I'm gonna quote a couple of sentiments
from Stephanie Sterling because what
they have said
about the video game industry
very much applies here
the first is
crunch is not a Triumph of the workforce
it is a failure of the management
if your workers have to do 77 hour work
weeks that is because you have failed
them as a manager as a producer as a
director as an executive whatever
somebody or everybody at that level has
failed these people who are actually
animating the final product
if they have to work those hours
you have failed them
and you have no business managing people
if the only way the work gets done is if
it's through a 77 hour work week if
that's what it takes to get something
done under your watch then nobody should
be under your watch and let me again be
really clear I love
this movie
this movie is incredible
but if it takes human suffering to make
it then I don't want it
a brilliant and it's
brilliant final product does not
justify treating anybody especially
someone who is the heart of what you
were even able to do a team of these
people a thousand people working in the
animation Department treating them like
this is not acceptable I don't care what
the final result is I don't care how
good the movie is that is not okay to do
and this is not new there's a lot of
overlap between the issues with
animation in general and stuff that goes
on in special effects because a lot of
special effects is frankly just
animation but it's why an oscar-winning
special effects team behind life is pi
went under because they had to Crunch
the hell out of their workers to get
done what they did
and whether that was director and Lee's
fault or the people specifically at that
uh post-production effect Studios fault
doesn't matter somebody's at fault for
that and it's not the people on the
ground level who work themselves to the
Bone and then lost their jobs or
similarly with Sonic the Hedgehog
with the big redesign of Sonic which
they got what like six months to do
six months to redesign remodel re-rig
reanimate
that freaking rodent
and that wasn't even a good movie
but again the quality of the final
product does not justify the method by
which it was made
and I know
I know
that some status quo Warriors are going
to come in here and be like well you
have an iPhone
and the manner in which that's made
also is unethical
and you're right welcome to the concept
of uh no ethical consumption under
capitalism it's all
that doesn't make any of it okay
should I be more up in arms about these
the working conditions that results in
this thing
yeah yeah I probably should
but I only have
so many spoons
I only have so much energy and
everything is rotten to the Core
foreign
right now today after learning this
about a piece of media that I adored
today I have the energy to deal with
this
so that's why I'm here and that's why
I'm talking about it and I don't care if
it makes me a hypocrite because of other
aspects of my life that I'm stuck with
because I live in this freaking Society
yes we live in a society and that
Society is broken
this is why unions matter
this is why workers rights matter
this is why deregulation
is the worst thing that has happened
to the capitalist system
I am at this point an anti-capitalist
I wasn't always
I would actually argue it didn't have to
come to this
capitalism could have worked
with regulation
but the regulation had its teeth taken
out or was dismantled altogether and
everything's gone to hell
and yes that is a little bit of a
tangent
something something capitalism bad and
all that thank you again Stephanie
Sterling
but uh doesn't make it any less true
and it is relevant
because it's what creates the systems
that all this comes out of
now
what does this mean
for me at least because
much like with the freaking Wizard game
nonsense I'm going to reiterate that
what I am about to say applies to me
and I will make my general statement
about what it implies for other people
if you are aware of what's going on but
I'm not going to tell anybody what to do
and I'm not going to tell anybody to
boycott this movie or boycott beyond the
spider-verse
and as much as it pains me to say what
I'm about to say
this might mean I don't watch beyond the
spider verse
not in the theaters anyways
maybe when it's streaming somewhere on
something I already have
what would it take
for me to see beyond the spider verse
well the big thing would be delaying its
release its current schedule release is
March of next year
and one of the people who was
interviewed for this article pointed out
there is no possible way that it can be
finished by then
so that means that if it does release in
March of next year
that means that maybe they hired in more
people
but even if they did it means they
crunched the hell out of the people
working on the movie probably even worse
than they did for across the
spider-verse
fundamentally
crunch happens because of a combination
of two things
unmoving final deadlines usually set by
somebody at the executive level
and then mismanagement by whoever is
directly in charge of the project
now across the spider-verse they get a
delay
but it still hit the mismanagement
beyond the spider verse if it does not
get a delay
then I have to assume that it is going
to be made under even worse
circumstances than across the
spider-verse was
and
I won't validate
that kind of abuse
of workers I won't do it
and that hurts
because I'm really excited for that
movie
if they delay it
maybe I'll consider it
I'm going to be trying to keep an eye
see what else comes out about beyond the
spider verse there's a very good chance
that this entire story about the
circumstances under which cross the
spider verse was made is gonna get
buried
movies still in the theaters still doing
very well
and
it's almost definitely gonna win the
Oscar
it's
it's a great movie
but the circumstances under which it was
made and what happened to the people who
made it
is at risk of
just getting left behind
and if beyond the spider-verse still
comes out March of next year you'll know
you'll know
that Sony believes that this is
acceptable
and doesn't care
and that the people in charge of these
specific movies
don't care
again
we'll see a delay is the minimum
absolute minimum beyond the spider verse
if it is anything close to the state in
which it was described by the worker who
brought up that one because he basically
said almost no work has started on that
because they were working on across the
spider verse up until the last minute
the theory was to get started on beyond
the spider-verse early as they were just
working on Final polish for a cross but
because so much work was being redone on
across the spider verse nothing was
getting ahead on beyond the spiderverse
so the idea of having the next movie out
in less than a year and that's assuming
that they aren't still tinkering with
the story
there's no possible way that that can be
done ethically there's no possible way
that can be done without abusing workers
I do not believe it
and again I will reiterate
yes
these people got paid
and yes in theory
they could quit if they found the work
unacceptable and some of them did
about 10 percent
a hundred people working on this thing
quit people's technical ability to walk
away
also isn't a justification any more than
the fact that they were actually paid
there over time instead of stiffed it is
a justification
because technically having the ability
to walk away doesn't make it practical
because especially in a business like
the movie business if you walk away from
a project that isn't finished
that's a bad look
because how does anyone who hires you
how do they know are you going to stick
around you're going to finish what you
started you didn't there will you hear
it's not that simple
the pure Logistics can they walk away
sure
is it going to be okay for them
career-wise to do so
Maybe
maybe not
will they actually have somewhere else
to go right away who knows
and not to mention the fact that this is
a creative field
these people aren't just sitting down
crunching numbers they're not doing data
entry they're animators they're artists
they're putting their creative energies
into this and if you
have not worked or had a passion or
Hobby in a creative field you might not
understand
what you are asking someone to do to
walk away from something they've been
pouring their creative energies into not
just their work hours but their creative
juices
that's
not an easy thing to walk away from
and that's even setting aside the
logistics
and none of them should have had to of
the ones who left
they shouldn't have had to
the fact that 10 of that Workforce felt
it was necessary to walk away
that's not a number to scoff at
that's not a number to be dismissive of
so
yeah
we can't have nice things
I'm really pissed off
I'm really angry
because
I believe
that this movie
probably would have been just as
brilliant as it is
with another four or five month delay
and not working people 77 hours a week
we'd have the same amazing brilliant
movie
but that's not how it works
people who are not on the ground floor
working those hours make the decision of
when it has to be done by
and then they make other people do it
I don't really have a wrap up for this
I'm just both exhausted
and pissed off
across the spider verse was made with
abuse
and I'm real ticked about that
whatever thoughts you have on this
drop them down in the comments and let's
talk about it uh please try to avoid any
excessively uh harsh personal attacks or
any threatening language
to anybody that's in this whether it be
Amy Pascal the Lord Chris Miller
or any of the animators who spoke out no
matter who you disagree with
be careful with your wording I can and
do delete excessively and needlessly
nasty comments
but uh I still want to hear your
thoughts
patreon is how I am able to pay my bills
and do this as my living and even if you
can't help me out there like share
subscribe also help and in this case I
feel that's a little bit more of a call
to action than usual because as I said
I'm very worried about this getting
forgotten and buried
and it shouldn't be
But ultimately what I really want you to
remember
and I hope the animators who worked on
this movie also know
that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council and I am just
running the meetings until next time
this Council
is adjourned
[Music]
foreign massive thanks to my patreon
supporters and in particular I want to
thank Robin Moore Zubin look full up to
rock the thing that goes doink in the
anime Ruth Oliver B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen the
oatha Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
bernabi likes the poodle Robin Powell
Tracy scrabot angry casparo Adam RDL
Taylor David Hall Shayla Gourley and
Rosalind Bennett thanks for your support
you can get your name in the credits too
if you feel like hearing me possibly
with it for several times before getting
it right
[Music]